(rock music)
- It's now time for
tonight's hashtag wars.
(audience applause and cheering)
(beep)
- [Host] Jen Kirkman.
- The UVA date rapists.
(laughter and applause)
- [ Host] Okay points.
(beep)
Marc Maron.
- The University of
Phoenix internet spam.
- [Host] Points.
(audience applause and cheering)
(beep)
John Hodgman.
- The Brown University
privilege checkers.
(audience laughs and cheers)
- Points.
(beep)
Yes, Jen.
- Duke University date rapists.
- [Host] Points.
(audience laughs,
cheers and claps)
(beep)
Marc.
- The Penn State you know-whats.
(laughter)
(audience cheering and clapping)
(beep)
- Points, Jen.
- The University of
Nebraska date rapists.
(laughter)
- Okay, points.
(beep)
- Hari.
- LL DroolJ.
- Points.
(audience laughs)
(beep)
Hari.
- Similac Shady.
(laughter)
(beep)
- (laughs) Grace.
- A Kanye breast feeder.
- Yes, points.
(laughter)
(beep)
Hari.
- The notorious B-I-G B-I-R-D.
(laughter)
- [Host] Yes, points.
(beep)
Grace.
(laughter)
(clapping)
It's not going to make
it happen any faster.
(audience laughing)
- I'll just sit it out then.
- A Small Sean.
- Yes, points.
(laughter)
(beep)
Doug.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh wait I'm sorry
we're out of time
for your answer. (laughs)
(laughter)
What is it?
- LL Coochie CoolJ.
(laughter)
- [Host] Yes, points.
(beep)
- Doctor Martin
Luther King size.
- Okay, points.
(laughing and clapping)
(beep)
Nick.
- Obese Witherspoon.
(laughter)
(clapping)
(beep)
- Rob.
- R Belly.
- [Host] Okay, points.
(clapping)
(beep)
Ari.
- Rob riggled to get
into these jeans.
- [Host] Points.
(laughter)
(beep)
Nick.
- Fat Damon.
- Okay points.
(laughter and clapping)
(beep)
Rob.
- Garth Brooks.
(laughter)
- [Host] Okay, points.
(beep)
Nick.
- Really huge Jackman.
- Points.
(laughter)
Genius.
(beep)
Nick.
- Michael Eatin'.
- Yes, points.
(laughter and clapping)
(beep)
Rob.
- Six pack Shakur.
- [Host] Yeah, points.
(clapping)
(beep)
David.
- What's happening,
seriously what's happening?
(laughter)
- Points.
(beep)
Jeff.
- Doctor who, what?
(laughter)
- Points.
(beep)
Jeff Ross again.
- House of bingo cards.
(laughter)
- [Host] Points.
(beep)
Koechner.
- World War Two and a Half Men.
(laughter)
- [Host] Points.
(beep)
Whitney Cummings.
- 30 Rock Hard Kidney Stones.
(laughter)
- Points.
(beep)
Koechner.
- Two Broken Hips.
(laughter)
(beep)
- [Host] Jeff.
- Shorts and Recreation.
- Points.
(laughter)
(beep)
Whitney.
- The Dick Van Limp Show.
(laughter)
- Points.